foreign
[Music]
guys we're doing another tomes of Terror
at long last uh this is my book review
series if you're new here
so as with most things that happen in
regards to my book reviews and my movie
reviews too to a lesser extent the way I
ended up actually reading and discussing
these two particular books because we're
doing two today uh this was completely
random how this happened
so both books actually popped up in my
Kindle unlimited recommendations and
both caught my eye for various reasons
I'm not really sure why the first one
did maybe it was the title or the cover
or something like that but it was just
kind of sounded good so that I just kind
of went with it I had never read
anything by either author before I mean
at least that I remember and I actually
didn't realize before kind of diving
into them that they were both novellas
so I figured that I would combine them
both into one review because like I said
I started reading the first one and I
was like oh my God this is super short
and I read it like in like a lunch hour
and a half you know what I mean and then
I was like well [__] I might as well
like pick another one you know what I
mean and I picked another one and then
that was a novella too and I was just
like [__] it I'm just gonna put them
both in one review because they were
both like really short they and the
thing about it too interestingly was not
only were they both under 100 pages but
they also kind of shared a very vaguely
similar theme of a man kind of looking
for love you know what I mean and having
things go horribly horribly wrong
um the approach of the stories was
pretty different but both of the stories
in the broad outlines were kind of about
that so I was like well they're kind of
similar in that regard so that's another
reason that I kind of put them together
now I will say
that both of these books or are what I
would classify as somewhat extreme
horror I mean they're not the worst
thing I've ever read like not by long
stretch so they're not like the sickest
of the sick or anything like that uh the
first one is kind of more on the
over-the-top Gory side while the second
one is more on the like Snot [__] and
vomit end of things but I'm gonna say
that like if extreme horror isn't your
bag then neither one of these books is
gonna be for you so I'm warning you
right now like I said they're not all
that bad but you know I've read like the
stuff that was like way way worse but if
you're not into it then you know it's
gonna be like rough going that's all I'm
saying so the first Novella uh was about
97 Pages at least the Kindle unlimited
version was and it was published in 2022
and it's called the fun house by Matt
Shaw now he's actually a British author
and cartoonist
now this book I the bulk of the action
takes place right around Halloween so I
feel like this would be a good quick
read you know around the Halloween
season I'm gonna say that even though I
liked the story kind of well enough when
I was reading it I noticed that it
didn't really stick with me all that
much after I finished it because I
actually like read it and then it was a
while before I actually got around to
doing this review because I actually
read another Novella in the meantime
that I'm also going to talk about so a
lot of details from it didn't really
stick with me so I had to kind of go
back and like refresh my memory and
stuff like that so I'm just saying that
so the story is told from the point of
view of a guy named Jim who basically
just seems like your regular
run-of-the-mill Garden variety average
English bloke
um who doesn't really have all that many
distinguishing characteristics I
couldn't tell you if he was described
what he looked like or any of his
personality traits or anything like that
he just seemed like a dude you know I
mean just like a stand-in
so he's out on the dating scene
and at the very beginning of the story
he's on a first date with a woman named
Laura who he met online
now because her dating profile seemed to
suggest that she might have enjoyed the
Finer Things in life let's put it that
way uh Jim has decided that he's gonna
try and kind of like impress her by
booking a reservation at this kind of
swanky restaurant that he can't really
afford now in spite of the Hefty price
tag like when the bill comes he's like
you know what it is that kind of thing
but in spite of that though like the
date goes shockingly well and Jim even
finds out that Laura is actually kind of
you know a somebody like sort of not
famous but you know she's kind of like
well known she like the staff at the
fancy restaurant like all know her and
stuff so it turns out that even though
she didn't really divulge this because
she didn't want it to be a thing I guess
um she comes from like a really wealthy
very prominent family in town
so Jim is pretty jazzed about this like
he can't really believe his luck and
better still Laura seems really really
into him like very obviously
um and this all seems entirely too good
to be true uh well surprise surprise
that actually does turn out to be the
case this is a horror story after all
and I'm gonna say too that even in real
life like if you meet a girl she's like
super super into you on the first date
maybe maybe like just proceed with
caution is all I'm saying so Jim and
Laura's relationship like over the
course of the short story
um kind of proceeds at a very fast like
Whirlwind pace and everything is just as
completely perfect as can be and after
only a very little while I can't
remember exactly how long it was but it
wasn't that long a time
um Jim buys a ring and decides to
propose to her
and he even decides you know to do the
whole like proper old-fashioned thing
which I don't even think anybody does
anymore but he's gonna go through the
whole rigmarole of asking Laura's father
who's kind of like this big muckety muck
like a business owner or something he's
gonna go to him and like formally ask
for her hand in marriage and [__] like
that so you know you know it's kind of
like hardcore if he's willing to do that
so Jim is kind of like anxious when he
goes to have this meeting with her dad
but Laura's dad is like all about it
like he thinks it's a great idea and he
even gives Jim a little tip
he says if you're going to propose to my
daughter why don't you propose to her on
Halloween because that is her very very
favorite holiday mine too
um and she would absolutely love it if
you did that
now Laura as it happens has already
invited Jim to this big like block party
type Halloween party that her family has
like every year
so he figures oh that's the perfect time
like I can you know ask her to marry me
there
so they go to the party and it's super
packed and like everybody seems like
really really friendly
little bit weird though a little detail
is that there's all these really big
nice houses in the neighborhood because
like I said this is kind of like a
wealthy area and then there's this one
sort of like dilapidated abandoned house
that's there for some unexplained reason
now shortly after this like you know not
too long into the party Jim starts to
feel a little bit woozy
so you know kind of where this [__] is
gonna go you know what I mean now I'm
not gonna spoil what happens
um you could probably imagine like what
happens from there so you know as I said
this was a perfectly entertaining just
bloody Little slice of Halloween
nastiness it had something I will go
this far it does have something of sort
of like a game style horror element like
maybe like something like
um ready or not or would you rather or
something like not exactly like that but
similar
so if you like that you might like this
kind of thing too like you know just
along those lines but I'm gonna say that
because it's so short like I said it's
only 97 Pages you don't really get to
know the characters
um well enough to get like entirely
invested in the situation and there
isn't really you know there's not really
the space to
have a great deal of history or context
to explain exactly how these
circumstances that Jim finds himself in
like how they ended up coming about you
know what I mean and like just the
backstory of it
um I actually think the fun house might
have worked better like as a longer
piece as a you know novel length because
it would have had more space for
character development and more World
building
um and you know this is a cool concept
overall I mean it's not super super
original like it's been I've read
similar things before but it is like a
cool idea and I think it could have used
more detail like I wanted to know more
about you know how did this come about
like why why do they do this crazy [__]
you know what I mean so it came across
to me like more like a teaser for a
longer work than kind of like a complete
self-contained story if that makes any
sense so yeah uh the next book on the
agenda uh this book actually
materialized in my recommendations on
can handle unlimited after I finished
the fun house and the thing that struck
me about this one was the weird ass
cover like I love the cover of this it's
like it's kind of unsettling like I've
seen other covers similar to this and
I'm wondering if it's like the same
artist I forgot to like look who the
artist was but I've seen like similar
artwork on other ones but I really do
like it
um so this book is called 100 match and
it's by Patrick C Harrison III
uh this book was also published in 2022
and it's also under 100 pages I think it
was only about 96 pages something like
that now I actually like after I read it
I went and looked to Goodreads and like
looked on some of the reviews and stuff
and I had to laugh because the author
himself wrote the first review of his
book so he gave his own book one star
and the entirety of the review was this
book is disgusting the author should
stick a fork in a socket and I was like
I do love a writer with a good sense of
humor so I really did I think that was
very very funny when I saw that so uh as
I mentioned this Novella is also more on
the extreme end of the horror genre not
so much Gore and like limb evisceration
and beheading and stuff like that as it
was as it was in the fun house this is
kind of more
low-key gross scenarios involving for
example you know [__] in Chile and
making people eat it
um you know like funneling vomit down
someone's throat like that kind of thing
you know what I mean
um and to me like which if you've been
around here already a while like you
know that I talk about this a lot
um that type of extreme horror is way
more revolting to me than the
over-the-top Gory kind like the over the
top gory kind I can handle pretty much
anything but the second you start
talking about like piss and [__] and
vomit I'm just like you know what I mean
so I'm gonna say
um 100 match did totally trigger my gag
reflex a couple times not gonna lie
about that so just as in the fun house
the first book that I talked about 100
match is told from the point of view of
a young man who is looking for love he's
out on the make you know what I mean
he's looking for the love of a
compatible woman
so our protagonist this time around is
named Bartholomew Bartley or he's
usually just called Bart for short uh
he's just this overweight balding fast
food worker like he works at a burger
joint and he lives alone after the death
of his elderly mother like his mom died
and like left him the house so he has a
place to live and he's actually thinking
of going back to school uh for his
teaching certificate which as you get
into the story and learn the character
that becomes even more horrifying you
know what I mean
so Bart is obsessed with Statistics
particularly in regards to dating like
uh for example like the very first line
of the book is you know point zero zero
one seven five two percent of
relationships end in homicide which is a
great that's a great opening line I have
to say
um so he also like as it goes on he
throws out more statistics he's like 69
percent of women prefer a dad bod to
like a ripped dude
um 98.3 of women percent of women don't
like being called fat uh 93 of Asian
American women are married before they
turn 40 like all that kind of stuff like
every few paragraphs he's always like
you know giving like statistics like
that so Bart is also something of a uh
quirky individual let's call him that
uh his hobbies include
um throwing cats into the street which
you know that was very upsetting there
there's animal cruelty in this as well
um so I mean this trigger warnings
there's lots of trigger warnings in this
um he drinks his own urine with a tea
bag in it so that's pretty special often
jerks off into the mayonnaise at work
and you know he's that's the mayonnaise
that he puts on everybody's burgers and
also um sticks his finger up his butt to
help himself fall asleep that's other
sets you
um also just hasn't aside uh he also has
absolutely no qualms about casually
murdering somebody if the situation
arises and the situation does rise like
quite frequently uh over the course of
this very short story
so everything he does is conveyed In
This Very unadorned like matter-of-fact
prose which kind of makes the whole
thing seem that much more disquieting I
guess because you just know I mean there
really are freaks like this like outrun
around loose in the world and this is
exactly what I picture their day-to-day
experience being like like to them it
would all seem everything they're doing
would seem like really mundane even
though they're obviously doing like
really horribly depraved [__] like in
between doing all the regular people
[__] like you know going to the grocery
store or the laundromat or whatever and
it's like oh and then by the way I'm
also like killing an animal and like
putting its legs in my freezer you know
what I mean it's like it's that kind of
[__] and there's really people like that
so I'm just like that's exactly what I
picture like a dude like that being like
you know what I mean so we get to spend
some time with Bart
um you know just establishing his habits
and his lifestyle if you want to call it
that
and then about a third of the way into
the story about 30 pages in something
like that Bart meets this very
attractive young woman seemingly quite
by accident she actually drops her
wallet I think in the grocery store
parking lot and he catches up to her to
return it and she is so appreciative of
his kindness that she later actually
like tracks him down at the restaurant
where he works and basically just like
straight up ask him out
so it turns out that her name is Sarah
and Bart is just immediately completely
smitten with her she seems completely
ideal in every way she's like exactly
what BART has always been looking for
his whole entire life like all his
statistics you know just in one in human
form you know what I mean she's very
very Charming she's very genuine she's
very down to earth and she seems like
very interested in Bart's life like his
background his family background his
future plans all that kind of stuff
she tells him
that she makes instructional videos for
a living and um so after they have like
their very first uh coffee date you know
they go and get coffee which is goes
very very well and very successful she
actually like asked him for his phone
number
um and clearly wants to see him again
and she's basically like hey what are
you doing tomorrow you know what I mean
so again like the eagerness with the
women
um that should be a red flag right there
but you know obviously the dudes in this
are like not the sharpest tools in the
shed in that regard so as I mentioned
before in regards to the fun house um
you know this whole situation obviously
is suspicious suspiciously perfect like
everything going really well and before
too long uh the reader finds out exactly
what Sarah's deal is because you know
that she does have a deal you know what
I mean I will admit that I pretty much
saw the ending coming like not exactly
but I got it pretty close you know what
I mean you probably will too if you're
paying attention to the story but I'm
gonna say that that didn't really hamper
my enjoyment I'm not really sure if
enjoyment is the right word considering
all the disgusting [__] that happened
this book
um but it didn't really hamper my
enjoyment is what I'm gonna say
um so again it's pretty [__] gross
I'm gonna say this is a pretty [__]
gross book and Bart in particular the
main protagonist is just
a vile main character but all that said
like he's still like strangely
compelling I don't think that main
characters necessarily have to be
likable they just have to be interesting
and he's definitely interesting but like
I said he's vile he's just like a vile
human being
um so how you feel about that is gonna
you know affect obviously how you react
to the novella now of the two books that
I read
um this one actually made a lot more of
a like a visceral impression and a lot
larger emotional impact I guess because
we're mostly like inside Bart's head
almost all the time so it's he was like
a character not you can't really relate
to him because like I said he's kind of
a monster but you know you at least like
know what his thought processes are and
stuff like that so you can kind of
connect with him in that regard so I
think I liked this one a lot better than
the first one but I mean I liked them
both just fine I don't really want to
[__] on the first one but I'm just
saying that this one made a lot more of
an impact like I still remembered a lot
more about it just because it was way
grosser it was just way more uh
unsettling just the whole vibe of it was
just like so nasty it's just made you
kind of want to take a shower afterwards
so it basically made a lot more of an
impression so um you know so as of this
recording uh which is May 2023 these are
both available to read for free on
Kindle unlimited if you have a
membership to that so you know if you're
into extreme horror and and are kind of
looking for or want to get into extreme
horror and are looking for a couple
short examples of it to kind of like you
know dip your toe in or whatever then
these two are like pretty good uh to do
that with like I said the fun house is
more like gory you know what I mean
whereas the second one is more like just
gross like putting gross [__] in
people's food and you know cruelty to
animals and you know vomiting and [__]
and stuff like that so you know
depending on what one you want I'm gonna
recommend though that if you're gonna
read the fun house I would save it for
Halloween because it is a very the whole
thing isn't said at Halloween but like
the big you know Climax and stuff like
that is set at Halloween so I think that
would be like a good it's weird because
the front of it doesn't really suggest
that it's like a Halloween story but it
kind of is in fact it gave me a slight I
don't want to go too far in this
direction but a slight Halloween three
type of thing maybe but like I said I
don't want to go too far in that
direction it's just it was just like a
little whiff of that that's what it gave
me but yeah so these two you know
perfectly good examples of extreme
horror so if you're into that then and
you know you could certainly do a lot
worse that's for sure so that will do it
for this tomes of Terror thank you very
much for watching please remember to
like And subscribe uh you know if you
enjoy the content really does help with
the algorithm and I will see you guys
again on the next one bye